edwin in greenville north carolina
starts off this hour hi edwin how are
you
hey chris hey dave thanks for answering
my call sure what's up
um so i'm 22 years old and i'm trying to
get back into college
whenever the pandemic hit i was doing my
last year
and most of my family uh was put out a
job
um now that it's been a year
everybody's gotten their jobs back or
got new jobs
and i reached out to my advisor
to see if i could re-enroll and finish
up what i started
but he said that i could if i did it any
later
i would have to restart the program so
question what kind of a school are you
in
uh it's uh east carolina university
so east carolina university won't sit on
your credits more than 12 months
horse crap
edwin i'm going to tell you call a
different advisor buddy yeah
like seriously that is that is the most
absurd thing that i've heard
that sounds like a sales tactic it
sounds like them trying to rush you in
to hurry up and get back preying on your
emotions so when are you supposed to
start back
in order to quote save these credits
according to this advisor
uh between uh summer and fall which is
june or this august and what's tuition
uh tuition for the last year
is i'm pretty sure it's around
uh six to eight grand i'm not
uh fully sure but yeah that's just for
my life okay so you know let's uh number
one we got to find out what the flip is
going on
we don't know so you need to know
exactly what you need
and let's pretend you're starting
classes in june to finish up one year of
school to get your four-year degree
right
regardless of if this advisor's accurate
or not on your credits are going to
disintegrate
but let's pretend that's the case let's
pretend that for for
discussion's sake that as you look into
it you learn
that it's 8 000 a year to go for the
last year
so to do the next semester you would
need four thousand dollars
right right and this is february
you don't you got until june to get four
thousand dollars
get to work right right right right now
i'm
uh doing a full-time job um
this plan about 20 a year and i'm
staying out here
uh and living off of that so far
um i was just in motive for
i should do like student loans and
pay as much as i could while i'm doing
it or
nope you need six jobs
so that you have four thousand dollars
extra laying around
by june if eight thousand dollars is
what the actual tuition is if you look
into it you need to be doing uber eats
uber feats
all the other things that are out there
uh at home depot
listen get after it buddy and this is
that mindset of you've got the first
four thousand
is the first goal right that's the
mindset that you're going to be in
and this i'm serious you're going to
give up some sleep you're going to give
up a lot but you're going to finish the
degree
and put yourself in a situation where
you're going to be able to make more
than about 20 grand
so it's just time edwin to light the
fire and to get more serious and to
develop a game plan
that clearly moves you in that right
direction and that means you're shutting
down a lot of unnecessary stuff
with friends because you've got a 4 000
goal yeah
but here's the thing dude if you just
wander into this
and you don't know your numbers and you
take advice from someone that you
haven't checked out their advice to make
sure it's accurate
and um you work 40 hours
making 20 grand you're gonna you're
gonna end up with student loans yeah
this is a
and then the then two years from now
that the two year older version of you
is going to be mad at the current
version of you
and so don't do that you know it's time
to get really sharp
really detailed really precise yeah
really goal oriented and develop some
serious work
yeah uh opportunities of some kind out
there delivering pizzas
you know six nights a week five nights a
week you can make 1500 bucks a month
which is more than you make at your
full-time job by the way
and so um you know you can do that right
now and
and you'll have the money to start
school in the spring and pay cash for it
and that's the only way we're doing this
so that's what you got to move towards
sir
that's your best bet by far